[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to how to help your body help
your mind so this is the talk that I've
given before a similar talk to like I've
given before it was called the science
science the science and psychology of
polarization or the science and
psychology of difficult conversation so
yeah I used to be a reporter cameraman
with Channel four News
and I made documentaries for the BBC and
for Channel four after that but I I
originally studied philosophy and I was
always really interested in kind of
slightly deeper questions and I was able
to cover on the news and and also at the
same time that I was doing the work for
Channel four News in the BBC I was doing
a lot of kind of what you might call
personal growth work meditation
therapeutic work Tantra loads of kind of
weird stuff that you might put under the
kind of heading of spiritual I don't
like that word very much but it was sort
of personal growth exploration stuff
whenever I go back to Channel four News
I always used to say I'd gone to a yoga
retreat because I didn't want to explain
where I'd actually been and so I was
really interested in kind of this this
this this nexus of like philosophy
personal growth and current affairs and
also getting this sense that a lot of
them are quite intertwined in that I
think a lot of the questions that we're
dealing with in the world the very least
have a psychological dimension and most
I think we're actually coming to a time
where a lot of the old stories are
running out and we've all got a sense of
the old stories of running out I think
we're actually starting to come to the
point where you need these sort of
deeper layers of philosophy and
psychology certainly to start making
sense of the world and it's not we're
kind of coming out of a very rationalist
paradigm and I think something new is
coming so I I left kind of traditional
journalism and documentaries and then
started up my own YouTube channel about
a year and a half ago called rebel
wisdom and we've got about 90,000
subscribes at the moment we're gonna
have about a hundred thousand fairly
soon and alongside that we also run
workshops and personal growth retreats
around some of the ideas and the films
so we look at topics like sovereignty
mindfulness presence but I'm going to
come to in this in this talk and we
recently put out a series that a lot of
the ideas that I'm going to share with
you are a link to called the science and
psychology of polarization and I I'm
convinced that these a lot of the things
that come from so this is Peter Levine
this is dr. Steven Porges Gina Ross they
are people who kind of straddle the
worlds of psychology and trauma and
neuroscience and conflict prevention and
this sense that a lot of there's sort of
very disparate ideas in different areas
that are needing to sort of come
together in a new synthesis it's a very
nascent area of trying to look at ok how
do you apply this deeper pull it deeper
psychological lens to politics and to
cultural issues and why this is such a
crucial question is because this sense
of polarization and a sense of
conversations breaking down how can we
possibly even start to deal with any of
the bigger social and cultural issues if
the conversations about them keep
breaking down and this sense of
polarization increasing and especially
on social media but also also pretty
much everywhere this that there are
there's there's a lot of focus now on ok
how do we even have generative
conversations and why do these
conversations keep breaking down and I
think there is something in the
zeitgeist there's a book how to have
impossible conversations by Peter
Bogosian and James Lindsey so that came
out in America two days ago it's coming
out in the UK in about three weeks
something like that and I've interviewed
Peter and interviewed James for films
that we're putting out in the next few
days and it's really it's it's a really
interesting book it's a really useful
set of arguments in their tactics taken
from hostage negotiation from kind of
ninja level cult
deprogramming tactics all of these like
how do you have positive conversations
how do you have conversations where
you're really interested in learning
what the other person has to say
well you're avoiding getting defensive
and so it's it's really well-written
it's a really good book so this is a
quote from the book the way to change
minds influence people build
relationships and maintain friendships
is through kindness compassion empathy
treating individuals with dignity and
respect and exercise in those conditions
considerations and psychologically safe
environments fantastic but this is James
Lindsay on Twitter one of the authors
you're a bit fix oh you're one of those
[ __ ] who confuse acts of terrorism
and I don't know if anyone here knows
spent a lot of time on Twitter but James
Lindsay is kind of notorious for being
combative and yeah being really
combative on Twitter so he's not
actually the question is why is it so
difficult for us to take our own advice
if if we were to ask anyone okay how do
we have positive conversations we'd all
give pretty much the same answer you
listen to people you don't dismiss them
it's a little bit more difficult to do
that in real life who here has ever had
an argument before if you didn't put
your hand out you can leave you don't
need to be here so it's fine just if you
could just put your hands back up again
keep it up if it was in the last week
keep it up if it was today great we've
got some experts some experts in here so
the idea of these sessions in here is
that they're a little bit more
interactive and hopefully to give you
some tips and tools what I'd like you to
do now and I know it's a it's an English
audience but I'm not ask you to talk to
someone talk to the person next to you
ideally someone you don't know and I'd
like you to talk to that person about
that argument that you had or the last
argument that you had but not about the
topic topics not important what it is
about how you felt how you acted and
especially you know how you reacted in
that mode
what you thought about the other person
what you thought about yourself what you
maybe thought afterwards so it's and
also just be aware of how you feel as
you're talking about it as well because
that can be a really useful guide to to
kind of how we feel about these topics
so I'm going to ask you to find someone
that you don't know to talk to for about
a minute and a half or two minutes if
one person talks the other person
listens and then we'll swap over in
about a minute and a half
you could just come to silence so I just
I just realized the other the other good
reason for picking someone you don't
know is that you you might actually be
here with the person you had that
argument with so don't need to rehash
rehash that if so you might need to take
it outside so who would like to share
just about what what came up for them
then as they were talking about it and
what how they felt in that argument
anyone wants a hand up and yeah yeah
I've been making a really conscious
effort to be really detached from the
ideas I'm talking about particularly on
social media to avoid being combative so
yeah particularly when the topic is a
motive or there's nuance in it so I
don't know whether that is a good thing
or not because social medias fertile
ground for ridiculous language the often
it kind of initially people don't really
know where you're coming from so yeah
I've just started doing it so I don't
really have any solid ideas about what
the results are gonna be
but and you're doing that because you
didn't always do that because I find
conversations on social media incredibly
frustrating because people don't allow
space for ideas outside they're kind of
dogmatic in transposition yeah anyone
else want to share about an in-person
argument that that's really interesting
it will come to a little bit about
social media in a second you all want to
share about an in-person argument yeah
at the back just you can decide between
you don't have an argument yeah might be
the second one dove today and more the
fact that actually when we first put up
our hands and you said was it today he
put his hand down and my hand stayed up
because it was most definitely today and
then because I have very good extra
sensual hearing
I could hear him actually talking about
the argument which he put his hand down
about his conversation so I couldn't
tell you that the content in terms of
what we were discussing actually came
back to a male-female dynamic and I know
we've talked a lot kind of throughout
the last two days about gender but
actually how men and women receive and
interact with opinions and how they
expressed them and how women can often
feel to make their point or to express
an opinion can come across as combative
when received by different audiences or
women aren't as confident to make their
points and that when they do make their
point and it's received in a way that is
diminished and it's made to feel like
their point has no value particularly in
an audience maybe where you actually
have a bit more of an informed view than
the general population but the general
population is the financial capital of
the world and so it doesn't really want
to hear it that you actually feel that
you're being belittled and that the
space and the air in which you can
express your own views is reduced and
therefore you will not express your view
in future you know who's familiar with
that sort of sense of dismissal kind of
and how that makes you feel like just
being dismissed that's that's one of the
key the key points that we'll come to in
a minute thank you thank you all for
sharing so yeah I'm gonna put up a few
ther clips now from the they're
originally from the world of trauma and
counseling but I think it's safe to say
that they they pretty much revolutionize
that world in the 70s and 80s the
podcast talks debates courses and
articles visit the Institute's of art
and ideas click the link on-screen now -
ie TV